build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
beauty pea building Gabriel - Shaw's
making new art out of old mechanical
objects he uses parts from typewriters
adding machines and any old computers or
technology and his hope is to be able to
continue to upcycle old items and help
create a way to deal with discarded
technology he has several different
genres including a skull series tabletop
sculptures and figurative sculptures
Matthew Georgia makes these amazing
elaborate origami designs some of the
designs are based off of other renowned
origami artists and some are of his own
creation he has hundreds of these folded
works of art including this dragon a
centipede Buddha and a Minotaur Jeff
Wright is a balloon artist who lives in
Bolivia doing charity work he was
challenged to make an Ironman 3 balloon
suit with less than 500 balloons
he ended up finishing it in just under
10 hours and used 364 balloons drawn
Mike Alcantara of comic collage art uses
pieces of old comics to recreate comic
book heroes all of his one-of-a-kind art
works are made entirely of comics and
they include Captain America the Joker
and Conan the Barbarian DJ Roomba
created Game of Thrones is for every NFL
team many have multiple designs such as
the buffalos bowed bent broken New
England by any means necessary and San
Francisco gold for our glory red for
your blood and now for the Street
Fighter Chronicles art from Armin
Akopian
photographer Joseph Ford made these
clever photos that mash up aerial
landscapes with fashion photography he
used aerial images he had previously
shot and worked with an art director and
stylist to come up with matching fashion
that would easily merge into the
landscapes some of the images took up to
12 hours to match the fabrics and prints
with the backgrounds flying Iron Horse
bluegrass has a ton of great covers and
tributes here's their version of Enter
Sandman by Metallica
and I
ah
the pain
of never-never-land in his own effort to
keep Portland weird that Darth Vader
unicycular rides while playing the Star
Wars theme on his flaming bagpipes
here's a cool system that allows the
audio of NES games to be played through
an acoustic player piano and robotically
controlled percussive instruments
finally here's the incredible music
video for Cruz del Sur by RV SB submit
your video piece as a personal message
here on youtube or share them with
everyone over at facebook.com/vsaucetwo
wo
click heroes to a brand new installment
of bep radio music created and submitted
by you guys also check out your bidipi
an entire video dedicated to just your
creations and as always thanks for
watching
and ten
see
just
Oh